i
[Música]
el reino unido puso en marcha la primera
jornada de vacunación masiva contra el
cob y 19 una mujer de 90 años se
convirtió en la primera ciudadana de ese
país europeo en ser inoculada con la
vacuna desarrollada por facer y vayan
tec unas 800.000 dosis serán
administradas en los primeros 7 días de
esta campaña
y el reino unido- da marcha atrás y
renunció a la legislación sobre el
mercado interior aspecto que contradecía
los términos del acuerdo de retiro de la
unión europea la decisión provoca una
luz al final del túnel de las
negociaciones con bruselas sobre un
acuerdo post preside en la víspera de la
reunión entre los líderes en la capital
belga analizamos este tema en minutos
y la fiscalía francesa solicitó una pena
de dos años de prisión y otros dos años
exentos de cumplimiento- para el ex
presidente nicolas sarkozy y sus
abogados acusados de corrupción y de
tráfico de influencias delitos que
fueron probados por el fiscal a través
de unas llamadas telefónicas grabadas
por la policía tenemos los detalles
desde parís
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora una mujer británica de 90 años se
convirtió en la primera persona en el
hemisferio occidental en ser inoculada
con la vacuna desarrollada por la dupla
faith ser valiente para combatir el kobe
19 las autoridades de salud británicas
indicaron que esta campaña de
inoculación a gran escala será una
maratón que podría prolongarse hasta el
próximo año unas 800.000 dosis ya fueron
recibidas en el reino unido- para el
inicio de este plan nacional de
vacunación
puede que no lo parezca pero esta mujer
estaba a punto de hacer historia esta
señora de 90 años es la primera persona
en el mundo en recibir por fuera de los
ensayos clínicos la vacuna que facer y
biotech desarrollaron contra el cofidis
y noir
y listo
justo una semana antes de cumplir 91 y
ya está lista para celebrar también de
barbados o algún lugar la vacuna será
distribuida a lo largo del reino unido
desde este martes dando prioridad a los
más vulnerables del país
estoy interesada en ponerme la si estoy
en la categoría extremadamente
vulnerable entonces espero que me la
pongan como parte de la distribución
pronto en algún punto y luego volver a
alguna clase de normalidad tanto como
sea posible
el primer ministro boris johnson expresó
un optimismo precavido durante su visita
a un puesto de vacunación en lo que fue
llamado como el día de mesa asombroso
ver salir la vacuna es asombroso ver
esta inyección en los brazos de la
nación entera pero no podemos
permitirnos un relajamiento ahora el
hospital universitario de croydon en el
sur de londres es uno de los 50 centros
clínicos que administrarán las primeras
dosis con el requerimiento de una
segunda vacuna 21 días después para
adquirir inmunidad este ha sido descrito
como el programa de inmunización más
grande de la historia distribuir las
primeras 800.000 dosis de la vacuna de
facer y biotech es todo un reto
logístico pues necesita ser almacenada a
menos 70 grados celsius
en los ensayos la inyección probó tener
una eficacia de cerca del 95% gobiernos
y agencias sanitarias de todo el mundo
seguirán de cerca el programa británico
de vacunación tomando nota de sus éxitos
y fracasos mientras esperan desplegar
programas similares en sus propios
países
el presidente electo de estados unidos
joe biden prometió aplicar 100 millones
de dosis de vacunas contra el cob y 19
en sus primeros 100 días de mandato
el anuncio llega cuando el país ya
superó los 15 millones de contagiados y
las víctimas superan las 285 mil por su
parte el presidente saliente de donald
trump afirmó un decreto para dar
prioridad a la vacunación de los
ciudadanos de su país ante antes que los
otros países alrededor del mundo
álvaro cordero tiene los detalles
eeuu superó los 15 millones de casos
confirmados y continúa como el país con
más muertes en el mundo a causa de el
coronavirus unas cifras en ascenso que
yo vaivén quiere frenar una vez comience
su mandato el próximo 20 de enero el
demócrata ya aseguró que hará
obligatorio el uso de la mascarilla en
la mayor cantidad de lugares posibles y
se aventuró a pronosticar que
suministrará a la población 100 millones
de vacunas en sus primeros 100 días stay
mojado que de tomb raider este equipo
ayudará a que al menos 100 millones de
inyecciones contra el comit 19 lleguen a
los brazos del pueblo estadounidense en
los primeros 100 días 100 millones de
inyecciones en los primeros 100 días de
la tercera ola de la pandemia está
golpeando con dureza a eeuu algunos
lugares como california se han visto
obligados a implementar restricciones de
nuevo con la esperanza de evitar un
colapso sanitario ya que el sistema
lleva meses con una presión muy alta
algo que ha servido para que donald
trump anuncie uno de sus últimos
decretos como presidente saliente dar
prioridad a los estadounidenses en sólo
unos minutos firmaré una orden ejecutiva
para asegurar
el gobierno de eeuu dé prioridad a
distribuir la vacuna a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses antes de enviarla a
otras naciones
jones el gobierno de donald trump ha
confiado desde hace varios meses en la
dosis elaborada por la compañía
estadounidense moderna aunque otras como
pzifer también tendrán presencia en el
país
la secretaria de salud de méxico anunció
cómo será el plan de vacunación contra
el cob y 19 que busca inmunizar a toda
la población de ese país los primeros en
ser inoculados serán los personas que
recibirán la vacuna a partir del mes de
diciembre de este año en un proceso que
se extenderá hasta el 2021 y serán los
trabajadores de salud y los grupos
prioritarios por estar en línea directa
de contacto con el virus el plan consta
de cinco etapas cada una de ellas con
una duración de entre 1 y 2 meses y
estima haber vacunado a todos los
mexicanos de manera gratuita en marzo
del 2022 méxico se convierte así en el
primer país de américa latina en poner
en marcha un plan de vacunación a gran
escala platicando con fai y en otros
temas el reino unido- renunció a la
legislación sobre el mercado interior
que contradecía los términos del acuerdo
de retirada de ese país de la unión
europea este anuncio da un cierto
respiro también llena de optimismo a un
día del encuentro entre el primer
ministro británico boris johnson y la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen con respecto a las
negociaciones sobre él
postres y que establecerá cómo será la
futura relación entre londres y bruselas
y que desde hace varias semanas están
estancadas para analizar este tema vamos
a saludar a pauline astro zayas abogada
doctora en ciencias políticas y sociales
también es académica de la universidad
de concepción la saludamos allí en la
capital de la región del bío bío en el
sur de chile muy buenas noches en
paulina y un paso atrás dado por londres
que pues por ahora la verdad llena un
poco de optimismo en cuanto a estar en
esta negociación pero porque ahora
londres da este paso y genera una buena
expectativa
entonces en el futuro de esta
negociación cuál es su perspectiva
cómo está santiago mira yo creo que aquí
influye mucho una estrategia o boris
johnson primero porque era una un arma
que tenía para negociar esto de estar
violando el acuerdo de salida al
intentar cambiar normas por el derecho
interno violando un tratado
internacional como es como era este
acuerdo que había llegado con la unión
europea y en segundo lugar porque la
llamada de bailén
y un tweet también de bailén y se lo
dijo es que el presi no podía poner en
peligro la estabilidad y la paz entre
las blandas porque vaivén tiene origen
irlandés y gran parte también digamos
una parte importante del electorado y
del partido demócrata también entonces
hubo ahí también una presión bastante
clara y al no salir reelegido donald
trump por supuesto que eso también pone
en problemas porque por ezio so en su
jugada frente a la unión europea
paulina este es un punto menos de
discrepancia entonces entre entre
londres y bruselas pero entonces como
están avanzando las negociaciones en
otras áreas difíciles como la pesca la
gobernanza que siguen estando estancadas
eso ya está un nivel político los
equipos técnicos que estuvieron
negociando durante todo este tiempo ya
llegaron a su máximo
el jefe de la negociación que es michel
barnier ya como quien le entrega digamos
está
esto lo máximo que pudo hacer la
comisión europea con el reino unido por
lo tanto hoy día ya se pasa a un estado
superior
esto es mañana cuando boris johnson
conducción al funk las leyes tienen que
ver cuáles son los temas en los cuales
no hay acuerde como tú señalas es pesca
donde tienen ahí es un anuncio incluso
de veto del presidente francés emmanuel
macro 11 es que no se le permite el
acceso a las aguas británicas a los
pesqueros francesas en segundo lugar
tiene que ver con que tú señalabas de la
gobernanza es decir también que no hayan
ayudas fiscales está ayudas estatales
porque el fondo lo que la unión europea
quiere evitar es que el reino unido se
transforme en una forma de no cumplir
con las normas de la unión europea
comparte tanto de ellos como de terceros
el mercado único sin cumplir con estos
estándares altos que tiene la unión
europea es decir un juego limpio o lo
que ellos llaman también esto de la
gobernanza interesante este análisis
paulina muchas gracias por explicarnos a
este tema explicarle a la audiencia de
francia 24 por estar con nosotros esta
noche en nuestro informativo avanzamos
con otros temas la fiscalía francesa
solicitó una pena de dos años de prisión
y otros dos años exentos de
cumplimiento- para el ex presidente
francés nicolas sarkozy por cargos de
corrupción y también tráfico de
influencias el fiscal le consideró
probados ambos delitos que fueron dados
a conocer por las grabaciones de varias
conversaciones telefónicas intervenidas
por la policía francesa entre sarkozy y
uno de sus abogados quien también
recibió una pena similar a la que se
suma también una pena adicional de cinco
años de prohibición para ejercer la
abogacía él caulle a barría periodista
de france 24 nos da más detalles de este
juicio contra el ex presidente y también
la sentencia que está por recibir
veinticuatro horas después de su
encarnizado discurso el fiscal económico
dio a conocer las penas que solicita
para el ex presidente francés nicolas
sarkozy su abogado tiene jackson y el
juez jubilado y así ver en este caso
conocido como de las escuchas o paul
mismo finalmente para el expediente que
se exponía diez años de cárcel ha pedido
solamente cuatro años de cárcel dos con
obligación de pena mismo castigo para su
abogado y para el juez un jubilado pero
además para terriers o pide cinco años
de prohibición del ejercicio profesional
en general ministerio público considera
que nicolas sarkozy y su abogado eran
conscientes de que estaban realizando un
delito de los que se le acusa que son de
corrupción activa y de tráfico de
influencias según la transcripción de
las conversaciones que pudimos escuchar
durante este proceso ambos intentaron
efectivamente conseguir información del
juez así ver y también que él los
ayudará en un proceso de que estaba
siendo investigado nicolas sarkozy a
cambio de un cargo en el principado
según el ministerio público si nicolas
sarkozy se arrepintió eso no quita que
haya querido cometer estos delitos y lo
peor de todo es que siendo presidente
habiendo sido un mandatario con su
actuar le hizo un gran daño a los
valores republicanos
y seguimos en francia el consejo de
estado de ese país se pronunció sobre el
proyecto de ley que defiende los
principios republicanos se trata de un
proyecto de ley propuesto por el
presidente manuel marco contra el
islamismo radical el texto será
presentado este miércoles al consejo de
ministros
ahora se llama ley de defensa de los
principios republicanos la palabra
separatismo ha sido borrada del título
del texto 57 artículos que ha recorrido
un largo camino desde que manuel makoun
presentó su plan a principios de octubre
desde entonces tres atentados de
islamistas radicales han golpeado el
país como medidas principales del
proyecto en primer lugar la lucha contra
el odio en línea con la creación de un
nuevo crimen el delito de poner en
peligro la vida de otros al difundir
información privada rudos nixon doy un
ejemplo público en las redes sociales
fui controlado por un policía su hija
está en tal escuela en tal ciudad se
convierte en un delito y esto antes no
existía saturio team of action israelí
existe para eso es lo que le pasó al
profesor asesinado se envió el patch y
cuyo nombre y dirección de la escuela
había sido publicado en facebook este
nuevo delito será castigado con tres
años de prisión y una multa de 45.000
euros la ley también prevé que se
condene la intimidación a los
funcionarios públicos aquí también se
crea un nuevo delito para aquellos que
atacan a un agente por motivos
religiosos
los ideológicos de los padres que van a
ver a un profesor para decirle deje de
enseñar caricaturas la libertad de
expresión mañana será un delito penal
el proyecto de ley también prevé el fin
de la escolarización en casa para los
niños de 3 a 16 años excepto por motivos
muy limitados así como un control
reforzado de las escuelas sin contratos
con el estado con la posibilidad de
cierre administrativo en caso de
infracciones graves y repetidas los
lugares de culto musulmanes tendrán que
ser más transparentes en términos de
contabilidad y finanzas las donaciones
extranjeras de más de diez mil euros en
particular serán sometidas a un declarar
la procedencia de esos recursos
las condiciones meteorológicas adversas
provocaron que el agua del mar adriático
inundará nuevamente el sector del centro
histórico de venecia la turística ciudad
del norte de italia venecia está
constantemente amenazada por
inundaciones provocadas por el
hundimiento del suelo y también por el
incremento en el nivel del mar como
parte del cambio climático
y así terminamos este informativo en
france 24 siga con nuestra programación
ya bien economía feliz noche
[Música]